[Music]
some veterans in our area getting a
second chance at a new life it is all
thanks to veterans court treatment
program which helps our veterans
navigate through the criminal justice
system and today 8 news now reporter
Victoria Saha was at a special
graduation to honor them
sometimes the bravest men and women
and find themselves in a weak spot
they're starting off in handcuffs and
wearing Clark County Detention Center
Blue judge Harmony Leticia is in charge
of the veterans treatment program for
the Las Vegas Justice Court overseeing
veterans who got themselves in trouble
veterans are very proud individuals and
they've been told to toughen up and and
do the job and not ask questions and and
work really hard and so when they're
struggling they often don't reach out
until they end up in a system like the
criminal justice system I think
sometimes for veterans the cars are
stacked against us just because you see
so many things while you're on active
duty Crystal McAdory a veteran watched
her husband Clarence struggle after
leaving the Navy stress got me into this
program Clarence was facing a
misdemeanor charge almost like I wanted
to give up I didn't want to do it I'm
going to take the charge because it's a
year of mandatory Court appearances
every two weeks it's a drug test he was
one out of five veterans who graduated
from the program and were also honored
by several organizations
[Applause]
with his record now wiped clean he can
look forward to serving our community in
a different way Victoria Saha 8 News Now
nationally there are more than 700
thousand veterans in the criminal
justice program here in our state there
are 288 veterans and treatment courts
right now again this option allows
veterans to take one year to go through
the program which also seals their
records you can find all the information
inside our 8 News Now app which is
available for download on both Google
Play and the App Store